قال رسول اوكراني ان الممثل الصيني الخاص
للشؤون الوراثيه بحث في كييف سبل التوصل
الى تسويه سياسيه لحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ويتزامن هذا مع اهتدام المواجهات على
مختلف الجبهات في اوكرانيا وتحذير واشنطن
من ان نجاح روسيا في اوكرانيا قد يشجع
الصين على غزو تايوان من جهتها قالت موسكو
ان الحرب حرب اوكرانيا ستستمر طالما ارادت
واشنطن ذلك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مغزى توقيت
اشتداد وتيره المعارك في اوكرانيا
واستخدام الروس اسلحه نوعيه في قصف كياب
ومدن اوكرانيه اخرى في هذا التوقيت ثم كيف
نقرا دخول الصين على خط الوساطه لانهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا وما موقف واشنطن من هذه
الوساطه في ظل توتر علاقاتها مع بيجين على
خلفيه قضيه تايوان ثم نبحث ونتسائل في
المالات المحتمله للحرب في اوكرانيا
وانعكاساتها على السلم العالمي في ظل
التخوفات الامريكيه من ان نجاح روسيا في
اوكرانيا سيشجع الصين على غزوه تايوان
[موسيقى]
بنت زمنيه مع احتدام المواجهات في جبهات
القتال في اوكرانيا
وتصعيد روسيا قصفها
اوكرانيه اخرى بل وادخالها اسلحه النوعيه
في الحرب وبموازاه الجدل بشان استهداف
موسكو نظام باتريوت الدفاعي في كييف
استقبلت العاصمه الاوكرانيه الممثله
الصينيه الخاص للشؤون الاوراسيه لبحث
تسويه للنزاع في اوكرانيا يومي الثلاثاء
والاربعاء وفق ما افاد به مسؤول اوكراني
رفيع المستوى لوكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه قالت ان المبعوث
الصيني ابلغ وزيره
ما سمته مبادئ استعاده السلام على اساس
احترام سياده اوكرانيا وسلامتها الاقليميه
وسيزور المبعوث الصيني روسيا وعددا من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي بينها بولندا وفرنسا
والمانيا علما بانه اعلى مسؤول صيني ي منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب
واشنطن التي قال وزير دفاعك ان النجاح
روسيا في اوكرانيا قد يشجع الصين على غزو
تايوان والتي حذرت مرارا من مغبه اقدام
بيجين على اي عمل عدائي ضد اتهمها وزير
الخارجيه الروسي
على استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا تحقيقا
لمصالحها بحسب قوله
م
لدينا معلومات على سبيل المثال ان ارمينيا
تتلقى اشارات تقول انضموا الينا اطردوا
الروسيه من اراضيكم واطردوا حرس الحدود
الروس واغلقوا القواعد العسكريه سنساعدكم
في ضمان الامن هذا استفزاز صريح الغرب
يحاول زعزعه العلاقات بين روسيا وبلدان
الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق ولا استثني
استمرار الحرب طالما وهي تصبه في مصلحه
الامريكيين
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذه العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه والباحث
بالمركز العربي في واشنطن ومن باريس
الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس اهلا بضيفيه
الكريمين نبدا بضيفي من واشنطن الدكتور
خليل
العناني عن
هذه المزامنه بين بدايه هذا المجهود من
قبل المبعوث الصيني
وهذه العمليات العسكريه النوعيه من خلال
الاسلحه النوعيه التي قامت بها روسيا ماذا
عن هذا التوقيت وان كانت رساله فما هي هذه
الرساله
انا اعتقد فيما يتعلق بالهجمات النوعيه
الروسيه الامر متعلق بعده امور الامر
الاول هو محاوله استباق روسيا لما يسمى
بحمله الربيع او العمليه الهجوميه
الاوكرانيه في الربيع طبعا تاخرت الان
اعتقد ربما تبدا بعد اسبوعين من الان او
ندخل في فصل الصيف فهذا نوع من اعمال
استباقيه تم استخدام فيها اسلحه متقدمه
جدا على سبيل المثال الاستخدام صواريخ فرط
صوتيه هناك حديث حول استهداف منظومه
باتريت الدفاع الصاروخ الامريكيه هناك
طبعا نفي امريكا لهذه المساله لكن بشكل او
اخر هناك التكفير في الهجمات ليس فقط على
المناطق المحتله ولكن هناك ما يشبه
التاكيد
بان المنظومه ربما اصيبت بعطب والحديث
الان هل سيتم اصلاحها من قبل الجانب
الاوكراني ام سيتم سحبها وبالتالي هذا
معطى مهم
هذا صحيح ولكن بشكل عام هناك شبه اعتراف
بانها اصيبت وهناك حديث حول اصابات روسيه
لذلك كان هناك نفر هذه المساله لن هناك
تاكيد على هذه المساله الامر الثاني متعلق
في رايي الشخصي برد روسي على الجوله التي
قام بها خلال ايام الماضيه لاوروبا قام
بزياره الدول الاوروبيه الحليفه الرئيسيه
زار فقط
عن هذه النقطه الان وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه تقول هناك تاكيد من قبل الجانب
الامريكي بان هذه المنظومه قد
اصيبت بعطب وهذا العطب يمكن اصلاحه فقط
لننوه لهذا الخبر العاشر تفضل دكتور وعدم
المقاطعه مره اخرى هذا صحيح لا عفوا ما
فيش مشكله خالص فاعتقد الامر يتعلق كما
قلنا قبل قليل باستخدام اسلحه نوعيه لاول
مره يتم الحديث عن اصابه منظومه طبعا
متقدمه جدا فيما يتعلق بالدفاع الصاروخي
هذا يعتبر التحول نوع في هذه الحرب فيما
يتعلق بمحاولات الصين الدخول على الخط
الامر يتعلق اولا بمحاوله حفظ ماء الوجه
هناك احاديث حول
الصين بدور الوساطه وهناك يعني بالفعل
هناك محاولات على مدار اخر اربع خمس شهور
باع خاصه بعد زياره رئيس الصيني لموسكو ثم
التواصل التليفون بينه وبينسك خلال مارس
الماضي من اجل فقط حفظ الماء الوجه نمره
واحد نمره اتنين محاوله ابداء صوره بان
هناك سعي صيني لفك الارتباط مع روسيا
ومحاوله تهدئه الامور لكن بشكل او باخر
اعتقد هي محاولات فقط شكليه لانه اولا ليس
هناك ثقه ليس فقط امريكيه فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه الصين قيام بدور وساطه لكن عدم
ثقه اوروبيه هناك حديقه كثيره جدا حول
وجود معه التعاون العسكري والاستراتيجي
الصيني الروسي هناك ايضا على ما يبدو في
الخلفيه يعني الصين مستفيده بشكل كبير جدا
من هذه الحرب المستمره لماذا لانها اولا
تؤدي الى انتهاء الى استنزاف امريكا في في
في الحرب الامر الثاني متعلق بتشتيت
انتباه امريكا فيما يتعلق بالصراع على بحر
الصين الجنوبي خاصه فيما يتعلق مع تايوان
وبالتالي الصين تقوم بهذه الوساطه ليس
بشكل جاد او بشكل حقيقي ولكن فقط بمجرد
حفظ ماء الوجه مجرد فقط من هذه المجمد
للسؤال فيما يتعلق بمصير هذه الوساطه
الصيني وسنثيره في هذه الحلقه لكن دعني
اذهب الى ضيف من باريس الدكتور زياد ماجد
فيما يتعلق بهذه الضربات النوعيه من قبل
الجانب الروسي استهدافا لكيف مباشره بعد
عوده زيلينسكي من جوله اوروبيه يقال بانه
تم تحقيق جزء مهم من طلباته من اسلحه
نوعيه استعداد لما توصل بانه الهجوم
المضاد من قبل الجانب الاوكراني ماذا عن
هذا المعتص لهذا التوقيت دكتور زياد
نعم يعني اعتقد ان هناك مستوى سياسي من
الجهه الروسيه هناك رغبه في اظهار ان
موسكو لم تتاثر بمجمل الضغوطات
السياسي والعسكري الذي امنه زالنسكي خلال
جولته الاوروبيه اضافه الى الالتزامات
الامريكيه الجديده بموازنات عسكريه دعما
الاكياس موسكت تبعث رساله مفادها ان كل
هذا لا يعني في الميدان انها ستتراجع او
ستقلص من عملياتها العسكريه بل تساعد
بهذا المعطى السياسي المستوى العسكري هو
ايضا استباقي هناك بعض الاشارات والخبر
العاجل الذي اشرتم اليه فيما يخص
الباتريوت هو دلاله لكن هناك ايضا مزاعم
روسيه في ضرب مخازن اسلحه وطرق امداد
لاسلحه قد تصل من اوروبا هناك مبالغه على
الارجح في ذلك لكن ايضا المعطى العسكري
يرتبط بما جمعه هو فشل فقط في جمع يعني
اسلحه طيران كان يطالب بها لان الالتزام
الاوروبي بارسال طائرات مقاتله يعتبره
الاوروبيون اعلان حرب مباشر على موسكو
انما جرى تجديده بمدافع ثقيله وباليات
مدرعه قد تمكن الجيش
اسبوعين وهذا مهلك ايصال الاسلحه الى
الانتقال الى اوضاع هجوميه او عمليات
هجوميه في اكثر من محور وطبعا هناك
المعركه المستمره في بخموت وكل ما بدها
ترمز اليه في كلا الجانبين لذلك تصعيد
الروسي الان كان متوقعا ايضا وقد تكون
جوله جلنسكي بدورها سباقا له يعني كل طرف
يستبق الاخر ليظهر انه مصمم على الاستمرار
في معرفه دي اشارتك وابقى معك ابقى معك
دكتور زياد باشارتك لجوله زيليسيا
الاوروبيه هذه المره اسالك عن الجوله
المرتقبه للمبعوث الصيني الى في هذه الى
هذه الوساطه وهو ارفع مسؤول يزور اوكرانيا
حتى الان ايضا في برنامجه زياره اوروبيه
لبولندا وفرنسا وكذلك
المانيا حتى الان الموقف الاوروبي يقول
بان هناك غموض في طبيعه الخطه الروسيه
المقترحه لاحداث وس اطه بين الطرفين
وبالتالي ماذا عن هذا البعد الاوروبي في
الرؤيا الصينيه في مقابل موقف واشنطن
اظن ان معظم الاوروبيين يريدون اعطاء فرصه
لكل مبادره المبادره الصينيه واحده من هذه
المبادرات وهناك مبادره جنوب افريقيه ايضا
لكن اعتقد ان العواصم تنظر بحذر الى
الموقف الروسي تعتبر ان مجموع الاتفاقات
التي عقدته بكين من فتره مع موسكو لجهه
موضوع النفط والتعاون العسكري والتقني
مكروه وسمى روسيا بالبلد التابع
للصين الان وبالتالي ينظر للصين كحليف
اساسي لموسكو ولو ان خبراء السياسه
الصينيه يدركون تماما ان بكين حسابات
مختلفه عن حسابات موسكو وهي باتت الان
تريد ايقاف الحرب لكي اولا تلعب دورا اكبر
في السياسه وليس فقط في الاقتصاد والتبادل
التجاري ولكن ايضا لان التضخم ومجمل الازم
ات ينعكس عليها وت
ريد من ذلك انما الشروط الموضوعه من كياف
ومن موسكو تجعل اي مبادره صعبه جدا
والنظره الى بكين لكونها مواليه او داعمه
لموسكو تقلل من فرص
هذه المبادره التي لا تذكر على ما سرب
منها انسحابا روسيا من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
كما تطالب اوكرانيا بل العمليات العسكريه
وعوده لمفاوضات ولمسارات سابقه صوتها
الحرب منذ فبراير 2022 ماذا عن مقاربه
الدكتور خليل العناني ماذا عن مقاربه
واشنطن الى حياله هذا التحرك الصيني
البارحه وزير الدفاع الامريكي في مداخله
امام الكونجرس قالها صراحه اي انتصار
لروسيا في اوكرانيا معناها فتح الشهيه
امام بيجين لتنفيذ مخططاتها حياله تايوان
هو موقف معلن وصريح حيال هذا الدور الصيني
في هذه المساله وبالتالي ماذا عن هذه
المقاربه وبالتالي معرفه مصير هذا التحرك
الصيني
[موسيقى]
طب اخر للصين على مدار اربعين سنه كان
هناك لم يبدو سياسه امريكيه تقليديه تقوم
على الاعتراف بالوضع القائم كما هو وعدم
يعني التحرك فيما يتعلق
بالسبارها دوله منفصله او كيان منفصل او
معزول عن الصين لكن خلال اخر عام هناك
تحول ما في الموقف الامريكي خاصه فيما
يتعلق بموقف المشارعين الامريكيين وراينا
خلال شهر اغسطس الماضي زياره قامت بها
نانسي عندما كانت رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي الى الى تايوان كانت زياره
مستفزه لانها كانت تعتبر اكبر واهم زياره
للمستوى على مستوى عالي جدا يقوم بها اعلى
مستوى في امريكا يعتبر النائب الرئيس في
حاله غياب الرئيس ونائب الرئيس رئيس مجلس
النواب ايضا قيام رئيس التايوان بزاره
امريكا خلال اخر اربعه خمسه اسابيع
وبالتالي هناك الشعور صيني متزايد ان هناك
دعم عسكري وهذا بالفعل هناك دعم عسكري على
الاقل دعم عسكري دفاعي لتايوان هناك دعم
ايضا بخلاف تدريب الجنود وقرانا وسمعنا في
الاخبار ان هناك تدريب لجنود من تايوان في
امريكا والعكس صحيح وبالتالي هناك مخاوف
المساله انا اعتقد تصريح لوستين هو يعتبر
استمرار الاستراتيجيه امريكا في اتجاه
الصين
هل واشنطن ستسمع
للصين ايا كانت خطتها بان تنجح في هذه
الوساطه ام ان الحسابات الامريكيه فيما
يتعلق باي تحرك صيني حيال الوساطه في هذا
الملف تحكمها حسابات امريكيه دقيقه
الاتهامات حتى من قبل موسكو ان واشنطن
تحارب في اوكرانيا باخر جندي اوكراني يعني
المساله الفصل في واشنطن كما يرى الجانب
الروسي وليس في كييف هل ستسمح واشنطن لاي
دور صيني في هذا الملف
اولا اعتقد انه الكلام حول امكانيه الصين
بقيام غزوه تايوان هو كلام اعتقد يبتعد عن
الحقيقه هناك محاولات صينيه نعم لردع
امريكا هناك محاولات صينيه للتاكيد على
انه تايوان جزء من الاراضي الصينيه لكن
بشكل او باخر من الشعر جدا توقع قيام
الصين بغزو تايوان على الاقل في الامن
المنظور لماذا الصين اولا تعتمد على تطور
الاقتصادي تعتمد على الاسواق الاوروبيه
والامريكيه وبالتالي هناك امكانيه للتضحيه
بهذه الاسواق الامر الثاني تعلم الصين
جيدا بانه اي غزو لتايوان يعني الدخول في
حرب استنزافيه هناك كتواجد عسكري امريكي
يعني متسع جدا في بحر الصين الجنوبي هناك
على الاقل 25 الف جندي امريكا موجودين في
اليابان هناك جنود امريكيين موجودين
امريكيه موجوده في كوريا الجنوبيه وفي
اليابان وفي اماكن اخرى وبالتالي تعتبر
مغامره كبيره جدا لكن ايضا قد تستخدم
الصين هذه المساله المتعلقه بروسيا
اوكرانيا كنوع من يعني ابداء نوع من الرد
على امريكا بانه اذا كان هناك قيام روسيا
بغزو اوكرانيا
بلا شك ان معظم الدول الاوروبيه باتت
تختفي الحرب
معها ازمات اقتصاديه وتوترات اضافه الى
ارتفاع موازنات الدفاع في اكثر من دوله
وهذا سيكون بالطبع على حساب موازنات
اجتماعيه مما يؤدي الى المزيد من التوترات
والاحتقانات وتخوف من صعود اليمين المتطرف
في بعض الحالات كما ان اوروبا تشهد تحولات
كبيره يعني ان تصبح المانيا من جديد دوله
معسكره بموازناتها وبصناعتها ان تتحول
بولندا الان او من الان ولغايه
الى الجيش الاكبر بريا في اوروبا مع طلبات
ضخمه للترسانه العسكريه كل هذا يعني ان
المزاج في اوروبا
والتحولات السياسيه في اوروبا تذهب
باتجاهات تصعيد وخوف من المستقبل لذلك
يفضل الاوروبيون ان يكون هناك حل لكن ما
يكرره الجميع الان بعد مرور اكثر من عام
ان اي حل يؤدي الى انتصار روسي سيكون
مقدمه لتنازلات اوروبيه اضافيه ولحاجه
اوروبيه اضافيه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لذلك حتى الذين كانوا في فتره
اولى يبحثون عن حلول وسطه ويحاولون اقناع
بالتخلي مثلا عن جزيره القرم باتوا الان
يقولون ان اي انتصار روسي في هذه الحرب
مرفوض وبالتالي هناك معركه اوروبيه في
اوكرانيا لحمايه اوروبا وليس فقط اوكرانيا
هل هذا يعني ان هناك رفض لاي وساطه لا
اعتقد ذلك الاوروبيه ستستقبل بيجين
ومحاولات الصين لعب دور وساطه لكن من دون
تعويل على الامر ومن دون اعتبار ان
المطلوب من الاوكرانيين التنازل الان خاصه
ان هناك من يقول بتعب موسكو العسكري ورغم
تصعيدها واسلحتها الفتاكه انما جيشها
والمساله ديموغرافيه المرتبطه بتعداد
الجيش المدرب والمجهز للاستمرار في القتال
بل تتطرح ايضا في موسكو كثير من التحديات
لذلك نحن في
مرحله اعتقد انها ستطول والحرب ستستمر
اكثر في الاشهر على الاقل في الاشهر
المقبله دكتور خليل حتى الان بيجين لم تدن
العمليات العسكريه كما تسميها موسكو عمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا ومع ذلك تقدم نفس ها
بهذا الدور وهي ربما الوساطه الابرز هناك
ايضا في الايام الاخيره هناك حديث عن
وساطه من قبل دوله جنوب افريقيا ولكن تبقى
الصين كدوله هي الاوفر او متقدمه عن بقيه
الوساطات
ما هي حظوظ هذه الوساطه في هذا الملف
وبيجين اي نعم لم تدن العابد ولكنها تقول
باحترام وحده اراضي الدول كعنوان عريض
لهذه الوساطه
كما قلنا قبل قليل عبد القادر اعتقد ان
الصين تحاول فقط حفظ ماء الوجه هي ليست
لديها امكانيه على الفرد اي نوع من
الوساطه على الطرفين المتحاربين وطبعا فقط
الحرب بين روسيا وبين اوكرانيا هي حرب
بالاساس روسيه غربيه تشترك فيها الدول
الاوروبيه وامريكا وراينا على اخر سنه ونص
هناك دعم عسكري ومالي واقتصادي ودبلوماسي
اوروبي وامريكي بشكل غير محدود بيتكلم على
اطول حرب العالميه الثانيه التي تجري داخل
اوروبا لان خليفه عام ونصف وقد تستمر
العامين او الى نصف عام تخش في عامين
واكثر من ذلك ايضا وبالتالي ليس هناك ثقه
غربيه خاصه امريكيه فيما يتعلق بامكانات
قيام الصين بالوساطه خاصه ان هناك كما
ذكرت قبل قليل هناك دعم صيني عسكري
واقتصادي واضح جدا لروسيا هناك ايضا عدم
اعتراف صيني بالعقوبات الامريكيه والغربيه
على روسيا تعتبر هي رئه للتنفس فيما يتعلق
بالنفط الروسي وبالتالي تعتبر شكل اخر
متورطه في دعم الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وبالتالي ان تؤخذ اي مبادره صينيه على
احمد الجاد امر بعيده جدا عن الواقع ومن
الصعب جدا توقع وجود اثار سياسيه ذو
المسيح الامر الثاني شكرا ليست هناك على
الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه هناك ليس هناك خطه
واضحه لهذه الوساطه هناك فقط مجرد كلام
كما قلت مجرد تصريحات دبلوماسيه هدفها فقط
حفظ ماء وجه الصيني فيما يتعلق بالصراع
والتنافس مع امريكا من واشنطن الدكتور
خليل العناني السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والباحث بالمركز العربي في واشنطن وكذلك
الشكر لضيفي من فارس الدكتور زياد ماجد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه الامريكيه
في باريس
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]